on ne pratique pas enfin on n'est pas
naturiste pas ce que je vais faire ce
que vous voulez faire et esker on peut
quant à lui se sont habillés le monsieur
là complètement bilingue anglais vous
avez l'air plus à l'aise que doc gynéco
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui elle est votre mieux qu'ils
découvrent les animaux et là je veux
savoir qu'est ce que vous défendez vous
défendre la liberté parce que nietzsche
a dit ah non on nous avait très être
libre c'est être nue et sans doute fait
malheureusement on a des milliers enfin
quelques milliers d'années de
conditionnement qui fait que l'on a
honte du corps mais il faut bien
comprendre qu'une paire de fesses ou une
oreille c'est à peu près pareil quand on
est dans le coma d'autre part vous savez
aujourd'hui que la randonnée naturiste
est pratique et d'une façon de plus en
plus importante
ouais pourquoi ça se passe bien ça se
passe bien parce qu'effectivement où on
n'a personne n'a envie de se voir
imposer quelque chose on est bien
d'accord
donc pour éviter cela moi ça fait 35
puis maintenant 40 ans que je pratique
la randonnée naturiste et à chaque fois
qu effectivement je fais entre
guillemets rencontre c'est pas une
mauvaise rencontre dans une rencontre
partie au tour des endroits qui sont ils
sont déserts où il ya personne
il arrive qu effectivement tu t'entends
ou peut-être surpris par effectivement
un randonneur tu arrivé voilà à quoi
vous vous sentez pas gêné de faire ça
parce que vous êtes obligé de vous
planquer pour attendait à ce qu
nationale est vous plan vous de vous
même vous planquer pour faire des
randonnées discerno qui a mené à mayama
l'escale j'ai pas dit ça j'ai pas dit ça
faisait vivre une expérience temps alors
justement on a une vidéo des randonnées
de nature regardez regardez c'est vrai
ce matin ces randonnées surprise
emmenée par julien vous mais le but
principal de l'expédition du chemin
c'est l'arrière ou plus exactement la
bourde de la rivière sur les serveurs
sont l'instant de son enfance et à dijon
après c'est sûr aux eaux
[Musique]
je les connais bien je veux c'est des
petits les a reconnus vous assurez les
enfants c'est vrai que le retour
si le retour à la nature fait qu'on a
des comportements effectivement que vous
pourriez qualifier d'enfantin alors les
gens revendiquent ce qu'on appelle le
naturisme en liberté donc le naturiste
en dehors des palissades
il faut savoir qu'on est quand même la
dernière population en france ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs qui est qui est
pratiquement dans l'obligation de
s'enfermer parce qu un ostracisme qui
est extrêmement important et ce sur la
table d or donc bien sûr quand on voit
des frères gestion ratatiner brody un
canal est codirigé courgettes ratatiner
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chérie chéri jamie village où se joue
sans vraiment prendre ça a vraiment à
coeur c'est à dire vous avez été
vraiment choqués vous avez des conjoints
ça marche ça m'a choqué oui quoi les
coaches les courgettes voir rater ça m'a
choqué ouais voilà
non mais je veux dire il ya plein de
choses qui engage aussi l'hygiène vous
allez où la liberté est habitué aux
touches au vin et on va rarement tâter
du pas avec son j'avais osé mais j'avais
déjà bel et bien cuites simplement fait
c'est bon pour clarifier un petit peu le
naturisme site une manière de vivre en
harmonie avec la nature caractérisée par
la pratique de la nudité partagé pour
conséquence le respect de soi le respect
des autres la vie n'y est pas et le
respect de l'environnement
bah moi ce film noir je vois quelqu'un
écrit fait des ébats amoureux et qu'il
ya des gens autour et du trading